un qualcosa di martina
mi piace questo programma cazzola
ciao ragazzi benvenuti a una puntata di
vita buttata oggi mi prenderò un tè con
cosma ma buongiorno buonasera
tutto bene guarda caso senti allora
sappia una cosa dimmi un
croccante
allora
conte ci siamo in bellezza questa
stagione sabbia
[Applauso]
poiché io che posso farcela possa
farcela
dice movimento oggi con te chiudiamo la
stagione di vita buttata questo non vede
che non troviamo più ma prima stagione
vita buttata
chiudere
[Applauso]
io le voglio queste cose però non voglio
che le tagli ma tu devi vedere chi sei
tu
posso offrirti qualcosa da bere grazie
alla rai qualcosa di parte
innanzitutto grazie per essere venuto
grazie per avermi imitato david o
mi fa male il misto club
vabbè fa mezzo
così è come oggi dal barman normale i
lunghi è il club se vuoi
allora vai che mai iniziato innanzitutto
come sta andando questo periodo
perché mi dai calci mentre sono a terra
bella come suonare dimmi una un ambito
in un ambito la la zio tasto dolente
diciamo che ha avuto questa relazione ok
ti è durata poco tre mesi è amata dello
stato no è che io ho un problema
veramente con le parti
tu sai cosa sono le parti
al soffritto una zona in quanto dai una
zucchina
c partiamo con la cosa delle cose
ci troviamo con l'ultima puntata de witt
e buttate
[Musica]
allora
allora ognuno delle parti metti che il
piccolo guglielmo se ne va in giro no è
un po ingenuo ok con guglielmo voglio
dire tutti noi tutti noi seri ma in giro
e la vita inizia a mettere qualche
ostacolo capisci e quindi il piccolo
vogliamo ha bisogno di proteggersi cosa
fa questa parte ferita per poter
sopravvivere e non sono cazzate la voce
è così prove crea una parte protettiva
che arriva ogni volta che guglielmo
sente una minaccia può capitare no
che nell'ambito delle relazioni le quali
io sono molti problemi questa parte
protettiva sia in iper allerta lei
scrive manda un messaggio no magari sta
parlo d'amore ma ti dico nonno questa ti
permettera al culo bello mandare a
[ __ ] i no no no non possiamo stare
insieme capisci ho fatto proprio un suo
show ma c'è una scritta di una carezzina
te ne prego che belle gottero qui tu sei
esattamente
quindi su sei esattamente
dell'unica persona per la quale vale la
soma del si tratta male perché gli piace
troppo
se perché la paura del
la delusione del tradimento capito che
da un momento all'altro quella persona
diventare un estraneo e ti mette da
parte e tale che tu preferisci mandarla
via per non stare male quindi prima che
i giochi capito e poi capitolo st gioco
scusa ma tu accada mai venire ho finito
tu dai a quella persona esattamente
quello di cui tu hai paura di 20 ciò di
cui si lavora con la persona ti tradisca
quindi tu diventi un traditore per filo
e per segno
per un'altra croccali
crocchette no in realtà siamo chieste
condanne letto
comando questo messaggio perché voglio
sfatare un mito della legge della l da
quando sono adolescenti sento questa
storia che le persone altro c'era un
piccolo persone basso celano grande non
è assolutamente vero io sono alto un
metro e novanta e passa mi assicuro che
non è così tutto questo comunque per
chiedervi ma ragazzo poi a quanto si
vede lungo innanzitutto io lasciando il
numero qua sotto in sovraimpressione da
lasciare a questa persona di un metro e
novanta si comunque assolutamente
rodrigo è un falso mito esiste un modo
secondo voi per comprendere e capire
perché io ho scartato dagli slip e ho
trovato sotto quisling di tutto cazzo si
mette le slip negli ambi noman
gli slip ma tu hai boxer sert lì tutta
la vita casalesi slip bianchi che rate
comunque un mio amico mi ha detto sì è
vero che mia mitico logica che lui lo
vede dalla sicurezza di una persona cioè
come una persona che rivela tutta molto
sicura così vuol dire che c'è la grosso
semplice una persona vuol dire ce l'ha
piccolo cosa ne pensi tu e smeraldo
ringrazio patti
magari questo tuo amico aveva un analisi
di sicurezza legata al fallo mette
invece altre persone non la sicurezza
economica e hanno questo tipo di
atteggiamento credo che quella sia una
insicurezza che non si nasconde molto
facilmente non basta un hummer del
piccolo se lei veicolo bene sono cazzi
amari forse no no no forse sì forse sì
ma sentiamo un altro audio quindi si
sente una clausola sentiamo un altro
audio sono bruciati o di racconto di un
altro caso ma nella mia vita essere
razzo rifiuta il mio invito opera da
chapelli allucinato in zona gialla the
castle hill e io ero una miscredente ero
incosciente perché le persone morivano
in brasile e io originato ma non aveva
assolutamente senso il brasile gela
border ho capito in zona gialle in
italia si poteva uscire non si poteva
prendere il gelato
brasile non si vede la porta poverina
raffaela questa persona si no scherzo
ovviamente però mi faceva evidenza che
viva no non sono d'accordo
o santa maria di maggio gori e forse un
dono
albergi mi
allora
[Musica]
mi piace questo programma cazzola
questo prototipo sexy di donna io sì non
si può dire il prototipo lo sai
tanto affrontò dibatto prototipo è
passata culo è certo imbecille che ti
piace e che giochi sono essere meno
sensuale
6 deludente nessuno si e mai incazzato
per questo sai perché no di me lo tocca
e detto che potevo fare tutto quello che
volevo
la gara voler fare di più
non dà fastidio perché troppo
intelligente come lo fai lo fai in un
modo che è come un etero dovrebbe farlo
con molto rispetto molta bontà e quindi
automaticamente la possibilità di
permettersi quello che si vuole ma ti
posso dire una cosa se non offendo la
sensibilità dei nostri ascoltatori e a
me è venuto proprio così perché proprio
nell'essere così maschio no di avere
questo aspetto aggressivo invece questo
rilascio questo rally se vi ricordate
e proprio poi dicono che se pare proprio
è un potere ed è delizioso perché scusa
qual è il tuo ideale
no è fondamentale che abbia una bella
voce altrimenti e maria
a essere infatti bella voce per te è una
voce e una voce elegante che parla
italiano ma ok ho detto posata però
anche quello che un po rotta magari
scarlett johansson molto bella se e
belle mani ok alla mentale e piedi
inclusi non sono fetish nel limite del
kitsch e poi deve avere un bel sorriso
ovviamente capisce che
deve essere molto intelligente molto
matura e ci deve essere quell'ironia che
si sposa perfettamente che una cosa che
ho sempre sotto quello che ho sempre
sottovalutarli
basta così
12 secondi
no perché l'oggetto di un aereo ed io
sono cose che non guardo le donne non si
fanno questi problemi le smagliature
cose all'uomo mentre che niente di
sbagliato è mai successo dico e nella
vita che tutti vi dico subito che non si
sa se sbaglio succedere cose che non
faccio mai successo ieri resto cosa cioè
pensato muse penso che questo è quanto
parco 2
allora io a dire a questo punto di fare
un giochetto insieme che bel gioco il
segmento
ti presento il nostro nuovo giochino
onto lo infili e poi
allarga ma dove la culla
queste rosano i dentisti no odio queste
cose perché io devo farti indovinare più
card possibili a perché non capisco come
dici mentre per il titolo
sono stato sono stato e sono stato
beccato
tre reti
in contr andiera il contrabbandiere in
credito imbruttito
sono stato bene farlo
che si fa per
beffato per fare no era impossibile
claudio claudio planeta balbettava
ina ina
ina
inavvertitamente un sonetto un sonetto
rarissimo il core piano il parrocchiano
paga pagava poco poco a farla
a casa a l'asta a costa a costa a costa
ha fatta apposta è mannaggia che schifo
o nanto pentra chiesto
ma è una tua ansia stupida la verità
mario mario chi si
immerse
[Applauso]
con
mario si immerse con la da da fuji
duffy sud da sud no tsubasa
dati con la muta
maglia
a cape scusa
[Applauso]
non
serve serve no sergio una
da viene da da
faccia
la parte la faccia
serie
a che è un nome trae dalla pappa dalla
mappa fino al punto di giuseppe
peppe
drago la
panna e fragole il
napoli e canale era quella cosa e coco
banana è quella di mercoledì non è mai
la città come daniele fischi
barba fragole cocco banale e vogliamo
sottaciuto detto no ma vai su sono la
mamma sarda non più tanto piccolo e il
mio credito questo mette un po in questo
è certo di incontri si rimettono in
gioco vi sentite di consigliarmi
qualcosa è arrivato di fare come si dice
da noi marras sa bagassa promette tanto
non lo so ma mi sembra qualcosa di zocco
esiste un grinder per uomini della rosa
cazzo è ma è come grinder che può essere
molto più io preferisco tenderti il suo
team che più velato no perché non sono
proprio tipo bancomat del seme ok hai
capito su una volta che è stato proprio
ci vediamo una volta una sola volta
appetita costa faccia la forcella
una sola volta è successo io qui lo dico
e qui lo nego allora è stato proprio da
ben ci vediamo ok fammi vedere fammi
vedere che andiamo facciamolo vai tu
perché fammi vedere che mercanzia senza
stiamo semplice stava andando a fare
solo quello rima che proprio c'è il
momento di farmi vedere listino degli
acquisti anche le donne dovrebbero fare
così gli converrebbe
tu pensi che le donne chiedono la foto
del camp
nou nel mio caso invece enrico caso di
molto più versi mia vita si può essere
diciamo che abbiamo
diciamo che abbiamo occasioni molto più
facili torino il discorso kinder nono
così però per le donne è terrificante
perché davanti si troveranno veramente
persone e auto delle esperienze guarda
ti racconto questa cosa in breve non
voglio essere pedante allora mi scrive
questa farsa fuzz mi sto facendo il
bagno nella vasca
famiglie nire gli occhi e mi fa anche se
mi porti una birra volo mi apre e non
era bellissima con belle gattino aveva
che sospettava parliamo un'ora
piacevolmente una persona intelligente e
se tutto va bene ti preparo la vasca
faccio si e siamo nel bagno candele sa
le cose pro fumose di che no aspetta ha
preparato tutto certo tutta bene
condotto il fatto che sono della leggere
e se n'è andata io ho fatto il bagno da
solo 20 minuti in quella vasca col gatto
che stava così senza nessuna scusa e
dopo che hai fatto il bagno se uscita
non sono scappato e lei niente stava in
camera a leggere piccole donne
probabilmente ma che cazzo ne so che
tiene bregaglio facciamo in sensi
incazzo
capitolo queste cose si trovano su
splinder e questa è una delle tante
possono stare guarda
[Musica]
scusa che prendo di silenzio poi
scapparne
mica tanto io mi mentale lui sì quindi
sempre prime
sale
the
[Musica]
beaver cannare è molto semplice questo
qui non ha interessi senza ragazzi alla
distanza non funziona ormai non è vero
mi dispiace io sono convinto la distanza
delle terre e la vicinanza e tutto amico
mio io voglio condividere con te ho
bisogno di sentire il tuo odore quando
mi manchi dove se è una cosa che uccide
invece sono dell'idea che a volte invece
la distanza aiuti perché così 16 i suoi
spazi sono gli spazi però non voglio
pensare che la distanza possa essere un
problema ne è un altro di palle però
inizialmente non è un motivo per cui
metodi anche solo per conoscere persone
possibile una cosa brutta i maschi
collezionano anche per noi a situazioni
cose solo per masturbarsi rendere la
cosa un po più avvincente realistica io
mando un messaggio non io assolutamente
che non mi scopro è masturbato in vita
mia per creare una cosa più realistiche
ti mando il messaggio non ci vediamo
magari una che nulla di sbagliato ma
così risponde capisci quello che voglio
dire no voi rifare per più lentamente
io dico ci vediamo quello fassi e basta
il ceo neanche ci ascolterà capisci
quello che intendo che già collezionato
si attenzione ai ragazzi attenzione a
questa cosa può sempre sembrare che
l'uomo abbia super intenzioni nei due
confronti
in realtà sono basate sul nulla e quindi
la cosa
crolla in 5 secondi e quindi aspetta
qual è il messaggio di speranza con la
quale vogliamo chiudere questa stagione
ne vita book pro come può fare una
ragazza deve aspettare le dimostrazioni
ma credo che sia molto
che bel messaggio
e bello da dare per chiudere vita
buttata io cosmati sono riconoscente non
devi eccomi sono ragazzi che dire siamo
arrivati alla fine di questa roma la
cerca di questa puntata al peccato sono
triste e questa stagione a perché può
essere un'altra si no la seconda cosmo
grazie mille per sia stato così e niente
ci vediamo
grazie ci vediamo sempre qui ma non so
quando ciao ciao
[Musica]